we are told the polynomial P of X is
equal to four X to the third plus 19 x
squared plus 19 X minus six has a known
factor of X plus 2 rewrite P of X as a
product of linear factors so pause this
video and see if you can have a go at
that all right now let's work through it
together so if they didn't give us this
second piece of information that has a
known factor of X plus 2 this this
polynomial would not be so easy to
factor but because we know we have a
known factor of X plus 2 I could divide
that into our expression and figure out
what I have left over and then see if I
can factor from there so let's do that
let's divide X plus 2 into our
polynomial so it's 4 X to the third
power plus 19 x squared plus 19 X minus
6 and we've done this multiple times
already we look at the highest degree
terms X goes into 4x to the 3rd 4x
squared times I put that in the x
squared or the second degree column 4x
squared times X is 4x to the 3rd 4x
squared times 2 is 8 X 8x squared and
then I want to subtract these from what
I have up here so I'll subtract and then
I'm going to be left with 19 x squared
minus 8x squared is 11x squared and then
I will bring down bring down the 19 X so
plus 19 X and so once again look at x +
xi x squared x goes into 11 x squared 11
x times so that's + 11 X 11 x times X is
11x squared 11 x times 2 is 22 X need to
subtract these from what we have in that
teal color and we are left with 19-22 if
something is negative 3 of that
something in this case it's negative 3x
and then we bring down that negative 6
and then we look at once again at the X
and the negative 3x X goes into negative
3 X negative
three times and so negative three times
X is negative three X negative three
times two is negative six and then if we
want to subtract what we have in red
from what we have in magenta so I could
just multiply them both by negative and
so everything just cancels out and we
have no remainder and so we can rewrite
P of X now we can rewrite P of X as
being equal to X plus two times all of
this business 4x squared plus 11x minus
three now we're not done yet because we
haven't expressed it as a product of
linear factors this one over here is
linear but 4x squared plus 11x minus
three that's still quadratic so we have
to factor that further and let's see
there's a couple of ways we could
approach it we could use well we could
try with something like the quadratic
formula or we could factor by grouping
and to factor by grouping and the whole
reason we have to factor by grouping is
we have a leading coefficient here that
is not one and so we need to think of
two numbers whose product is equal to 4
times negative 3 so we have to think of
two numbers let's just call them a and B
a times B needs to be equal to 4 times
negative 3 which is negative 12 and a
plus B needs to be equal to 11 and so
the best that I can think of they have
to be opposite signs because their
product is a negative so if I had
negative if I had if I had positive 12
and negative 1 that works if a is equal
to negative 1 and B is equal to positive
12 that works and so what I want to do
is I want to take this first degree term
right over here 11x and I want to split
it into a 12x and a negative 1x so let's
do that so I can let's just focus on
this part on this part right now and
then I'll put it all back together at
the end so I can rewrite all of this
business
as 4x squared and instead of writing the
11x there I'm going to use this blue
color I'm going to break it up as a 12 X
so plus 12x and then minus 1x No
these two still add up to 11 X and then
I have my minus three and then let's see
out of these first two what can i factor
out let's see I can factor out a 4x so I
can rewrite these first two as and if
this is unfamiliar to you I encourage
you to review factoring by grouping on
Khan Academy so if we factor out a 4x
that's going to be it's going to be
we're going to be left with an X here
and then we're going to be left with a 3
over here and then these second two
terms if we factor out a negative 1 so
I'll write negative 1 times we're going
to have an X plus 3 and so then we can
factor out the X plus 3 so let's do that
I'm running out of colors so i factor
out the X plus 3 and I am left with X
plus 3 times x 4x I'm going to keep
these colors the same so you know where
I got them from 4x minus 1 this is a
very colorful solution that we have over
here and there you have it I factored
the second part into these two factors
and so now I can put it all together I
can rewrite P of X as a product of
linear factors P of X is equal to X plus
2 times X plus 3 times 4x minus 1 for X
minus 1 and we are
[Music]